that's right i think i think we started
off with a good intentions is about
making sure we identify individuals who
have concerns being radicalized will be
coming extremists and we work with them
to ensure that they're either locked up
or they're directed into other areas so
that they stopped being extremists and
being a danger to our communities but
actually what's actually happened it's
become counterproductive and that the
Muslim community as a whole has huge
concerns there are examples of the
community in Birmingham that was up in
arms when prevent cameras were put into
CCTV cameras were put in and it's very
very well documented the concerns that
the local community had about the fact
that they weren't consulted in a in a
timely way it's roughly what do you
think I mean is this interface they're
just being run too crudely to bees no I
actually find the comments made by mr.
bobrucz are they quite quite offensive
and quite problematic first of all I
think they're in a front to the scores
of parents that are actually engaging
with police and authorities to actually
prevent their children from being
radicalized in the first place secondly
for all the practitioners and the police
themselves who are working diligently in
this area but also I I'm not surprised
that mr. Babur finds these the prevent
program now toxic in it in his own words
because I know that certainly whilst he
was putting Muslims in a box by setting
up the National Association of Muslim
police the organization that he worked
that particular organization at the time
worked very closely and supported an
organization the Islamic Human Rights
Commission that supported jihadist
extremist that actually on a recording
that we've got in January asked people
students to undertake civil disobedience
and of course worked with cage quite
extensively who've been exposed as an
organization to supports extremists and
jihadi John so I'm not surprised
anything believes it to be toxic because
the very people that it's designed to be
toxic for a finding it toxic and this
probably seems to be the kind of people
that mr. Babu has in the past work with
and may well be talking to now most
member what's the response to those
charges there well I think that's
completeness of rubbish what we remember
is Quilliam foundation got a million
pounds from the prevent strategy so you
shouldn't be surprised that the cuillean
foundation are saying it's a wonderful
I think the reality is Quillen are a
discredited organization they do not
have the confidence of the Muslim
community they are a mouthpiece for
government agencies so what we really
need is a real opportunity to challenge
policies work with the agencies and as a
police officer I worked very very
closely with agencies to stop crime
happening so you know I'm very very
surprised at some of the allegations
have been made you know but we really
need to work closely and we need to
acknowledge where things aren't working
and if an organization has had a
million-pound like William I would be
very very surprised if they say actually
the money you gave us has been very
poorly used no I think that's that's
again rubbish I think because quilliam
when it was first set up in 2007 did
receive 300,000 pounds a year that money
stopped in 2010 / 2011 in the last four
years we haven't received any government
funding whatsoever and if that's Adam
even on your program we've been very
very critical of the government saying
that they've not been doing enough to
prevent people from becoming radicalized
in the first place which is something
mr. bob was certainly when he mentioned
that prevent is meant to do X it wasn't
it was actually initially designed when
I launched it with roof Kelly to
actually prevent people from being
radicalized in the first place the bit
about engaging with people once they've
been radicalized came much later I think
there are people i mean we heard this
from cage last week in connection with
mohammed emwazi who seemed to think
there any attempt to create an interface
to intervene is somehow offensive and
simply pushes people away but the wider
society is concerned that there are a
small minority people who are getting
radicalized and they wonder what they
should do about it mr. Babu yeah I think
I think kgs views are reprehensible
there and you know justifying the the
actions of invited was shocking I think
what we need to be doing is we need to
really be very very honest we need to
hear what the Muslim community are
saying and not create a situation where
we become counterproductive you know if
my math is right down low though I do it
well I think it's inevitable but if my
Matthew's right three hundred thousand
pound a year for three and a half years
is a million pound and I think what
we've got with quillian is that they
have they do not have the confidence of
the community if you go to key
organizations like the Muslim Council of
Britain if you go to organize a big some
of the biggest mass season under moss
you will say you'll hear people say that
they don't have any trust in quilliam
foundation quillian is is has taken that
money it has not been independent it is
hardly surprising they come on to your
program at them and say that prevent is
working when in fact we are still having
people going across to Syria now the
estimates are 30 to 40 individuals I
think we have some really really
effective and hard-working police
officers who are doing a really good job
and I think you know we shouldn't take
away from that but what we really need
to be doing you start asking some
questions around safe Guardian as a
whole if you look at Children's Services
you know have we had any serious case
reviews we need to really need to
understand the lessons that we can learn
so we're a young person has been a
victim of grooming online grooming what
we've done to learn about that
individual and we seem to have taken a
very very different approach we are
quite rightly condemning Oxfordshire the
police in Oxfordshire Thames Valley
Police and and the children services in
Oxfordshire for failing in the way that
they dealt with all the young lady young
women that were groomed by the
pedophiles but we need to be looking at
these 15 year old girls they are
children we need to make sure we
understand how they were groomed you
know and it's via the internet and what
we're doing around dealing with the
internet and ensuring BPL those that
work with our young people to mr. rafi
yeah I think I think there again therein
lies the problem again mr. Bob was
talking about moss in East London Muslim
Council of Britain these are the very
same us that are inviting hate breaches
and it's been exposed many times and the
government has decided that they will
not entertain them and so of many other
authorities but I think herein lies
another problem if mr. Babel doesn't
know whilst he was a person that was
receiving prevent funding himself from
his department's in London what and how
youngsters have been groomed therein
lies the crop if you like that the whole
issue we know what it is we know that
certain organizations in the UK
our purveying a particular islamist
narrative which is based on hate
preachers which is based on this utopias
what's gonna do about it but two things
first of all once people have been
identified as showing support we provide
an intervention I rehabilitation d
radicalize or arrested we have to but
the bigger water I mean we're going to
win that is to prevent people from being
radicalized in the first place build the
resilience so that when they youngsters
are faced with the ideas online or
offline they've got the ability to push
back we don't do that it doesn't matter
who we upset and who we don't upset
we're not going to win this struggle
well obviously very much divided user
thank you both for joining me